Obama says Venezuela is a threat to
national security
Venezuela really haven't we've been here
before first with this guy and now with
this one
while the huffing and puffing here are
four things to know about the u.s. and
Venezuela president Nicolas Maduro says
Washington was helping to plot a coup
against him the White House brushed it
off these latest accusations like all
previous acts such accusations are
ludicrous as a matter of long-standing
policy the United States does not
support political transitions by non
constitutional means to which reporters
literally said the US has a
long-standing practice of not promoting
what did you say
how long standing is that because it
just isn't true one example is in 2002
when the u.s. tried to help stage a coup
in Venezuela itself
it worked for about two days because of
then President Hugo Chavez is
overwhelming support the u.s. is also
funneled roughly ninety million dollars
into the country since 2000 via USAID
USAID sponsors humanitarian projects but
also has a history and supporting us
friendly political groups in Latin
America it's hard to make sense of all
this rhetoric when business between the
two countries is pretty good Venezuela
is the fourth largest supplier of oil to
the US and in turn the u.s. exports
billions of dollars in goods to the
country each year but things start to
become clearer when you look at who is
in Washington right wing sectors - cold
war warriors that still have a lot of
influence in Latin Latin American policy
and also a Cuban American contingent
that's in Congress and that has very
important committee positions in
December Obama signed a bill sponsored
by Cuban American Democrat Robert
Menendez that slapped sanctions on seven
Venezuelan officials Washington accuses
the officials of violating human rights
during anti-government protests last
year in which 43 people were killed
thing is a large number of the 43 were
supporters of Maduro as government as
well as police the violence came from
both sides Venezuela is a deeply divided
society the socialist policy Hugo Chavez
implemented for 14 years and the ones
Maduro continues mostly benefit the poor
they include social programs largely
funded by the country's oil money under
Chavez poverty was cut in half and
extreme poverty went down by 70% at the
same time the murder rate has gone up
though it's been called otherwise
Venezuela is in fact a democracy the
Constitution guarantees civil political
economic social and cultural rights the
right to education work housing rights
of ethnic minorities and gender equality
electoral monitors say the voting system
in Venezuela is reliable but that
federal and private campaign funding is
a problem another thing to know is that
there are no term limits on presidents
mayors or governors now Venezuelans are
feeling the weight of an economic
recession combined with plummeting oil
prices for them it's meant shortages of
basic food and medicine
and skyrocketing inflation it's caused
major discontent even among Chavistas
those who support the government every
country in Latin America has come out in
support of Venezuela against the USS
stance the country has played a major
role in bringing the region together
politically and economically and
consequently excluding the US and that
could also be taking Uncle Sam off who
knows how things will shake down between
the two countries maybe they're just
destined to be enemies with benefits